Once upon a time, there was a boy who was
born into a family of simple tailors in the
middle of sub-Saharan Africa. The boy’s father
wanted him to continue the family business,
but the boy wanted a better life and one night
decided to leave his home and go to Europe.
To cross the sea the boy built himself
a raft. But once he left the shore,
there was only a little wind and it didn’t
take long for his supplies to run out. And
there he was: hungry, and lonely, floating
in the middle of the mediterranean sea.
Imagine you live on the coast of
Southern Europe and one morning,
read about the boy's fate in a local
paper. Should you yourself try to save him?
Four influential philosophers — Aristotle, Mill,
Kant, and Nietzsche — can help us answer this,
and other difficult moral questions
with their respective theories.
Virtue theorists like Aristotle ask:
how to live a good life? The best life,
according to him, is the life of someone who
demonstrates excellence in aspects of a virtuous
character: the capacities for emotion,
theoretical ideas, and practical wisdom.
Aristotle would argue that if helping the boy is
a manifestation of a personality that’s virtuous,
then you should save him because
being a person of good character
is what matters. What that exactly
means, differs for every one of us.
If you are rich and powerful, saving the boy could
be easy. It might still be the right thing to do,
but it doesn’t reveal much of your personality,
and hence isn’t particularly virtuous.
If you have little to no means,
your decision to save the boy
is much harder. If you still try to do
so, then this truly reveals character,
is virtuous, and is something
you probably should try doing.
Utilitarians such as John Stuart Mill, ask which
action increases well-being for most people?
So when faced with a choice they do what
seems most beneficial to most people as if
they could calculate what consequences
lead to the highest net happiness.
When thinking about saving the boy's life, you
should consider all the happiness the boy and
his family get, the joy it may bring you, and
the benefits for society now and for generations
to come. This you then compare with what else you
could be doing — known as your opportunity costs.
For example, instead of risking your life at sea,
you could work the day in a coffee
shop, and donate the money you made
to an effective charity which then saves
two kids from starvation somewhere else.
Comparing the two options, you decide
not to save the boy, but instead work,
donate and double the total potential well-being
of humanity. Some call this effective altruism.
Deontologists like Immanuel Kant,
focus on the 'intent' rather than
consequences. They believe in universal
moral laws, such as “Don't lie. Don't
steal. Don't cheat.” The golden rule is
the so-called categorical imperative:
our decisions are then morally right when they
can become a rule everyone else should follow.
If you help the boy, because
it makes you look good,
your intentions are wrong because you
treat him as a means to an end and we
don’t want to live in a world in which
false heroism is a universal moral norm.
If you save the boy, because you want to
live in a world in which helping those in
need is always the right thing, then you
should do that. You should even do so if
you have reason to believe that the kid may
end up taking advantage of your kindness.
Friedrich Nietzsche would ask what’s in your
own interest? He argued that self-interested
behavior is morally right as it makes
us stronger. And if we are stronger,
so is society. Acting against your own interest
is immoral because it hinders this development.
So if you want to help the boy,
because you think that is good for you,
do it. Help the boy. But if you
think saving the boy could hurt you,
don’t. It’s not your responsibility to save
those who are too weak to help themselves.
So what do you think? Did any of the four help you
with that decision? If not, here is one more idea.
Scholar Moshe Koppel made the interesting
observation that Utilitarians and Kantians
don’t use their own moral principles when trying
to falsify each other’s theories. Both rather
appeal to a feeling — as if we all, inside us,
actually know what’s right and what’s wrong.
Kantians would say: you don’t want to live
in a world in which children die in the open,
because you decided to save two strangers instead.
Such behavior just doesn't feel right. Correct?
Utilitarians would counter: surely
you wouldn’t want to save, say,
a psychopath from drowning who’d then
go ahead to kill you and your family,
just because helping people is always right
by principle? That just feels wrong. Right?
So now tell us, would you save the boy? And why?
Is your decision based on the character you strive
to become, an analysis of costs and benefits,
behavior we want to see in the world, for your own
self-interest, or does it maybe just feel right?
Share your thoughts in the comments below!
If you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation,
you can support us. Visit
patreon.com/sprouts. Just visit us,
learn how it works, and what’s in it
for you. We hope to see you there.
And if you are a parent, or an educator,
check our website sproutsschools.com There
you can find this and other video lessons,
additional resources, and classroom activities.
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com